Hey guys before we get started
I've got an exciting announcement the king of random has been nominated for two Streamy Awards this year including best show of the year
But we haven't won yet. We need your help to take 10 seconds jump over to Twitter and tweet the hashtag
#TKORFORSTREAMYS that's all it takes to cast your vote just tweet #TKORFORSTREAMYS and with your help
We'll hopefully be up on the stage on September 26th. There's definitely something floating around there, but we're gonna drink it anyway
What's up guys welcome back?
I'm grant Thompson the king of random
And I'm at Pat from game theory and film theory we brought you back out to the ocean today because we're doing another experiment with
Ocean water absolutely we are answering a comment from
Craig videos who asked if you could take seawater and turn it into actual drinkable water, that's right so in this experiment
We're on the opposite. End of the spectrum rather than taking the salt out of salt water
We're taking the water out of the salt water and trying to make it drinkable so really cool experiment Craig
We're doing this for you. Let's see if we can make it work. Let's go so to help us with our experiment today
We've got this little contraption off Amazon. This is basically like a wood powered distillation apparatus. Have you ever heard of an electric distiller?
I have not actually there are electric water distillers, but the reason I got this one is because it's actually powered by wood
Yeah, so you're doing an old-school style wood propane exactly so if you know if there's emergency
And you can't get water anywhere all you have to do is light a fire underneath
Yeah, you can theoretically take any water
And it will vaporize it and then distill it where it collects it back into the centre so for my like
Apocalypse bunker. This is a must-have. I must have and I'll put a link down in the description so we can get on Amazon
I'm not saying it's worth it. This was like 400 bucks
Whoa which I think is way too much
But I'll put a link down the description in case you want to go hashtag humble brag about how much you spent on this
That's right, so our goal for today head down to the ocean get a big pitcher full of water
Then bring it back to my place throw it on the stove. See what we're able to cook up do it get to it
Let's do it bottoms up in a couple hours going for a swim guys
Oh, that's that's way up in the pants. It's way up in the pants at this point
You're good
Whatsit Miss Frizzle always says when you do science get messy take chances
Definitely got messy. That's good man. Good thing to see it's waterproof
I hope let's reel it in see we got all right. There. You go, sir
This guy is an animal hey, you got to get water somehow so you just ran out there
And he took it barefoot, and this is what we've recovered
I think we got a little bit more than salt water in here you see a few other little things floating here
Maybe a little bit of sand who knows what but we're gonna take this back to the house now
We're going to load up our little
Distillation device and set it on the stove for a few hours and see what we get out there you go
Let's go do that next so here. We are guys. We're back in the house. We have a stove top with a gas flame
We've got our sea water and now all we have to do is transfer all the sea water into the distiller
Crank up the heat and let it sit
That should be plenty
You can actually see like your Kennex
We got like some feathers floating around there some other organic materials
This stainless steel mesh is gonna help suppress all that and if everything starts bubbling it's gonna keep it all down
There we go just floats right on the top there
This is the tray here that will actually collect the water
You know this just sits down on top right? Oh bing bada boom. We place this little cap on top
This is to help vent volatile organic compounds those things that are lighter than water, and then we simply fire it up
Now let's talk a bit about what's happening inside the pot here as the water starts to boil it turns into steam and the steam
Rises and it goes into these condenser units here
Where it hits and then condenses into liquid and drips back down inside the system now
We know that when water evaporates that leaves everything behind
So theoretically the water coming out of here in steam form should be relatively pure
And we can actually speed up the condensation by using something like ice or cold water on top of the plates
And then all we're gonna need is something like this cup or a bowl to put underneath the spout to collect all the fresh water
That drips back out now. We just have to sit back. Give it a little bit of time and let it boil
Hey, so finally some water is coming up to spout and it looks to be fairly clear
And it's poured out really quickly and consistently - it is this whole thing is really hot right now
You can see everything's steaming the glass is steaming water steaming where everything is hot
Stevi
Four hundred dollars well spit all we have to do now is let this sit for about thirty minutes or so so we can collect
A whole bowl full of stuff right and then we can let it cool down and give it a taste test
Guys check it out it has been about fifteen minutes now
And you can see we've already filled this glass all the way full
And this thing is just cranking out so I actually had to switch out to a larger bowl because we're getting more water a little
Bit faster than I expected
So check it out guys this has been running for about 35 minutes now. We've filled up an entire bowl with water here
I'm not quite sure how it tastes yet, so we're gonna take it off
Let it cool down for about 10 or 15 minutes, and then give it a taste test in the meantime
Let me take this top off so you can look down inside and see what all that sea water looks like boiling away
You see how that screen mesh is kind of holding all the bubbles down and there's quite a bit more water in there
Which is fantastic?
Huh
All right so quick update guys. We just transferred all of our water into this picture for convenience
You can tell by the steam coming on the top. It's still quite hot so we're gonna stick this in the fridge
Let it cool down a little bit
And then we'll do the taste test when it tastes a little bit more like pure crisp water as opposed to
As much as you probably enjoy drinking hot water. You know you can make myself a cup of tea all right
I'll stick in the fridge all right a chopper Stephanie's watermelon. How's that Stephanie loves her watermelon perfect all right cool?
Good news. We put this thing in the freezer. Just to cool it down a little bit quicker
You can see it's getting frosty the temperature the water. It doesn't feel like super cold. Yeah, but it's definitely not hot anymore
It looks like
That's point there are things floating around in there
Good
It's just like orange juice. This is water pulp style
Call yourself a cuppa over the teeth over the gums look out stomach here. It comes
There we go all right bottoms up cheers sir official taste test here we go
I
Taste absolutely zero salt it 8-0 Sol's your salt
Does have some sort of aftertaste though mmm that's all tea and that's actually the taste of distilled water
Because distilled water takes everything out of the water
So they actually add taste back into it really they do we actually have some distilled water with humanitarians
Oh, that's a great idea uno momento por favor
That's Spanish for
wait right here
Yes, so this is official distilled water. This is from the store. It has a Best Buy a date
Yeah, see this says it's distilled water purified by steam distillation
Huh okay filtered and ozonated, so it should be the same process all right butters up. Here's once again
Pinky up means it's fancy
You see you still get that same after - yeah, yeah, it's colder though. It is a little bit warmer. Yeah
I think warm water. Just doesn't taste as good
But as far as like the taste goes that I say that taste is very comfortable. It is very similar no salt
You know see you life. I'm actually impressed with how good the ocean water turned out mmm?
It's a completely viable solution it opposed the pugilistic world where clean water is not available - would you like to have some more
processed ocean water please do
gotta stay hydrated nope
The amount of water that I got out of the ocean for you how much how much pure water would that give you it's all
evaporated down oh gosh
I say most of it really yeah, you're gonna be able to capture most I'd say probably under 98% recovery rate
Maybe 97 Wow because in our experiment we found that only 3 percent of the mass was actually salt
Yeah
so theoretically the other 97% should be water anything so I think by out here able to capture all the vapor if you collected a
Full bottle of ocean water I would expect you to almost recover a full bottle of distilled water you
Know it would just be a lot more drinkable right so if you have a lot of extra time on your hands
You can do it - you challenge us to take sea water and make it drinkable
We did that did it and I'm very excited. I hope you learned something new big
thanks to Matt Pat for joining us for this experiment for risking his safety to dive out to the depths of the ocean and
Rescue sea water for this experiment. Hey, it was touch-and-go there for a little bit. Hopefully
I wasn't too salty for you today
And this was a pleasure doing this experiment his link is down in the description below
So you can go check him out give him some support random nation unite let's go show him some love
Baby shout out to Craig videos for suggesting the topic of today's video Craig you can go check your youtube inbox
We are sending you 25 bucks Chuck
Don't spend it all in one place. We'll be looking for in the next video. Talk to you then
Figure 747 whoa
Lanning you're attracted
Laughs say he's having flashbacks to his former life hundred percent distilled pure water Subscribe to Crushr YT for Captions!
We'll see
There's a lot in there go ahead table event area oh
It's just oh oh
That's why you wear safety shoes. If safety red shoes, and not your oh my gosh
I got wet at the beach, and so let me take off my socks. Thank you. Hey guys quick reminder about the Streamy Awards
We've never been, but we'd love to win
So if you would take 10 seconds jump over to Twitter and tweet the hashtag TKO our four streamys with your vote
There's a chance we could be up on the stage on September 26